[Music]
winter brings its challenges for horse
owners from freezing temperatures to
managing icy conditions whether you're
new to horse care or looking for a
refresher I'll walk you through the best
practices for keeping your horse safe
warm and healthy this season so let's
dive in so let's start with blanketing
Basics blanketing can feel overwhelming
but it doesn't have to be horses
naturally grow with thick winter coat
that acts as an insulator by trapping
air but some horses may need extra help
so here's what you need to
consider when to blanket if your horse
is clipped underweight elderly or
struggles to maintain body heat
blanketing is a
must but if they're healthy well fed and
grow a full winter coat they probably
don't need
one choosing the right blanket there are
three main M types lightweight sheets
for mild cold medium weight for jelly
weather and heavyweight blankets for
frigid
temperatures proper fit ensure the
blanket doesn't rub or restrict movement
it should sit snugly but not tight
around the chest and belly always check
straps daily to avoid dangerous snags
and the other things you need to check
every day sometimes multiple times a day
whether you know temperature
changes was it really cold in the
morning and so you had the sheet and
then a heavy winter blanket on and then
a turnout rug and now your horse is
outside and it's
45° like you you need to be able to
monitor these things and make the
blanket
switches when need be because not being
able to do that not
monitoring every couple of hours you you
could you know create conditions uh for
your horse that are not good you know
like sores uh excessive sweating and
then it gets cooler later on now they're
sweaty and wet and then it cools down
and now they're freezing so there's so
many things you have to consider when it
comes to blanketing I'm lucky Dakota
grows a polar bar coat in the winter
time what I do for him is I Curry him
almost
daily I will curry him to make sure that
there's no hair sticking together that
it's standing
up and so that you know when it's really
frigid cold and windy he just turns his
butt to the to the wind and continues to
munch on his
hay now we're going to jump into
managing frozen water oh
boy not fun
one of the worst parts of winter in in
my humble opinion but access to Fresh
unfrozen water is a non-negotiable for
horses even in the dead of winter
dehydration is a silent threat and
definitely can increase the risk of cic
so here's some tips to manage water
during freezing
temperatures invest in heated water
options heated buckets and trough
deicers are like saers make sure they're
properly grounded to prevent shocks I
don't use them inside the barn of course
Dakota would only come into the barn if
it was terribly horrible horrible out
meaning like sleet
and combined with the frigid
temperatures um what or or if he weren't
feeling well then he would come into the
barn but I would use an insulated bucket
before I would use one of those heated
flat-sided buckets buets because they're
dangerous and many of barn fire have
occurred because of those those buckets
so I don't use heated buckets in the
barn however I have invested in the big
they look like muck buckets but they're
heated um those work really well
consistently I've had a lot of issues
with the drop in heaters not being
grounded properly and and the problem
guys is within the heater itself you can
have
everything set up properly grounding
rods Outlets that are grounded the whole
nine yards but you could have a faulty
heater my suggestion to you is to
wherever it is that you're purchasing go
to a a you
know store like Tractor Supply or
whatever I'm not promoting any one of
those but go there in person bring a
voltage meter with you and right in
front of the cashier before you pay for
that check it many of them are being
bought and they're defective and they're
shocking your horses once you shock your
horse when they're trying to get a drink
of water then you really increase the
risk of dehydration and impaction colic
because they're going to be
terrified to drink from that bucket
again okay so again I have found those
big not big troughs but they look
they're the size of a muck bucket um
that are heated have worked consistently
the best haven't found any shock issues
and again but make sure that your
Outlets are grounded and you got to
check them you know how you check them
barefooted and you stick your hand in
there yep rather you than a $10,000
$20,000 colic surgery right
okay here's some DIY hacks for icef free
water if heated options are not feasible
try insulating your buckets with foam or
wrapping them with a heat retaining
cover I've seen people build like a box
for a stock tank and then putting a
layer a thick layer of straw under the
stock tank and around it and setting the
stock tank in there that will help
insulate it get it off the
[Music]
ground oh add a floating ball that can
help delay freezing the other thing we
used to do was we had um big aquarium
bubblers that we put in our in our
troughs and those worked really well
kind of like Pond bubblers right you
ever see they do that for the Wildlife
on backyard big ponds and they have this
you know they have a fountain or they've
got bubblers going works you got to make
frequent ice checks guys you got to
break and remove the ice multiple times
a day if
necessary just make sure you always have
a rubber Mallet or a crowbar to help
make it a little
easier and you want to encourage
hydration so you might have to add some
electrolytes or a small handful of salt
to your horse's feed to encourage
drinking I do give Dakota Himalayan salt
in each one of you know twice a day just
a little but enough and they they they
drink adequate
amounts you can soak your
hay or warm the water slightly which
helps too too can also help during cold
snaps now what I love about those
heaters I mentioned the ones that we use
outside the heated muck buckets is what
they look like is they do keep the water
at a really comfortable temperature so
it does encourage a lot more uh
ingestion of water hydration is just as
crucial in Winter as in summer so you
need to keep a close eye on your horse's
water intake okay if you have multiple
people like we do that are rotating bar
chores and feedings we always before we
leave we inform everybody else that this
is how much water was ingested like it
was down to a quarter of a bucket or
trough I topped it off on and on and on
and on and on so we keep each other in
the loop about forage intake feed intake
and especially water intake all right
speaking of
food we need to touch on feeding for
warmth
because horses are natural foragers and
digestion generates heat making proper
feeding a Cornerstone of winter care is
imperative so here's what we need to
focus on forage forage forage on cold
days you got to give your horses extra
hay it's their main heat source and it
keeps their digestive system working
properly obviously you're going to
monitor body condition you need to check
your horse's weight regularly so that's
where like having your horse under a
blanket all the time and if you're not
pulling those blankets and sheets and
all that and getting a look at your body
your horse's body condition you might
miss
something okay you need to use a weight
tape or even just feeling along the ribs
to make sure they're not losing
condition winter supplements consider
adding some fat sources like rice brand
or flax seed for the extra calories if
your horse is struggling to maintain
weight and of course a favorite warm
Mash treats offering warm beet pulp or
soaked ha cubes can provide hydration
and comfort on cold days just make sure
it's not too hot every bite counts in
Winter plan your horses's diet to keep
them warm and
healthy now we're going to talk about
turnout and safe
turnout turnout is absolutely vital for
a horse's mental and physical health
even in winter but icy conditions
absolutely can turn playtime into a
hazard so the number one thing you want
to start with is you have to prepare
your Paddock clear the walkways in hight
traffic areas of any snow and ice or you
know most of it you can add sand or
gravel or even a non-toxic deicing agent
for better
traction snowball hoof
care snow can compact into hard walls
under their Hooves and it can cause a
lot of discomfort guys you want to apply
a non-toxic hoof oil or spray to prevent
buildup or even hoof boots if
necessary monitor the weather extreme
cold wind or free freezing rain May
warrant keeping them in the barn but
they still need to get daily
exercise let's not forget about the
buddy system horses stay a lot warmer
and happier when they can interact with
their herd mates so group turnout is
ideal when it's safe you need to balance
safety with the benefits of fresh air
and movement to keep your horse
happy and how about grooming and hoof
care winter coats are nature's blanket
but regular grooming is still essential
it's about more than just
appearances grooming is your chance to
check for issues and I do that's why I
do that every single day with Dakota I'm
checking his feet I'm
checking his legs for any inflammation
I'm checking for boo boos I mean
everything you want to focus on
hygiene because mud wet and moisture can
cause a lot of skin problems like rain
rot use a curry comb and a stiff brush
to clean their coats thoroughly
like
often don't forget about hoof
maintenance pick those hoofs daily to
remove mud snow or ice and keep an eye
out for thrush or cracks caused by wet
and freezing
conditions shedding tools oh these are
my
favorite for clipped horses consider
using fleece or wool coolers after
exercise to Wick moisture and prevent
chills I like the shedding tools and I
do use them because most of them will
separate the hair and get it to stand up
too um and also when I see the shedding
begin and that let's face it that can
start in late February early March it's
indicative of warmer weather to come and
you know
not for nothing but your grooming
routine it's a great way to bond with
your horse and ensure that they're ready
for any kind of weather you know I love
my time spent brushing Dakota and I know
he enjoys it as
well you need to monitor for health you
got to do a visual because winter can
amplify existing health concerns
especially for older horses or those
with special
needs you should be proactive about
their health and you can use these tips
to do
so regular vet checks ensure your horse
is up to date on vaccines and deworming
as winter can still bring parasites and
respiratory
problems Dental Care horses with dental
problems can struggle to chew hay now
you need to look for that right if you
start seeing qubing which is where
they've been chewing and chewing on hay
and then they spit it out and you find
these Globs of wet or in the winter
Frozen chunks balls of chewed forage
that they didn't
swallow that's telling you there's
there's some dental issues and you need
to because they need that forage guys
you need to make sure there's nothing
going on in that mouth that their teeth
are able to chew if you have to start
feeding soaked hay pellets to add extra
forage then that's what you need to do
you know and our elderly citizen
um chewing can become an issue so we
have to make sure we're we're looking
for these signs and and taking care of
them schedule that Dental flow if
needed we're going to look at body
condition scoring so again run your
hands along their ribs the back the hips
every week to monitor their weight early
prevention is
key and again we're going to go back to
this blank blet checkups remove those
blankets every day inspect the skin and
coat for rubs Source or even injuries
you just don't know prevention and early
intervention are your best allies in
Winter horse
care you know winter can be an
absolutely beautiful time to enjoy with
your horse but it does take preparation
and care and by following these tips you
will keep your horse healthy happy and
thriving no matter how cold it gets gee
whiz yesterday was single digits we
still had fun yes I was
like totally you know I had the ball of
clava on I was layered but I was
comfortable so I got to still enjoy my
my baby while I was feeding all the
horses and doing the chores and it was
awesome well all right that's that guys
if you found the video helpful please
like comment and subscribe for more
equestrian content I really enjoy making
this content for you I am six decades as
a horse
Enthusiast and I enjoy sharing my
content with you thanks for watching and
we'll see you next time
[Music]
oh